we love crossword puzzles they're my
favorite thing to do and you host the
new crossword puzzle game show called
people puzzler and it's with people
magazine this is freak out
amazing good and it's game show week
here on our show so we thought it'd be
fun to play
drew's clues
[Applause]
okay all you've got to do is solve our
super simple crossword puzzles and
you'll have 30 seconds to solve each
category
now if you get two out of three puzzles
correct each of our vff's
will get 100 gift cards to the thermal
apparel brand
heathholders.com and you get gloves
socks hats you're going to be warm and
cozy
plus we're also gonna donate five
thousand dollars to leah's charity of
choice which
is feeding america thank you are you
good at crossword puzzles yourself
i'm not i'm not really that great only
under pressure i mean we play games here
all the time i have a closet full of
games my family is always here at my
house
thank god but you know it is very
competitive here especially like
games like charades where my mother
still doesn't understand when i tell her
if i do this
like it means film i mean i don't know
how i want to explain it to you
[Laughter]
i want to be there during one of your
charades lots of fights lots of fights
just on getting the rules straight so uh
but
timed crossword puzzles my brain just
shuts down but let's try it let's go
get that competitive spirit going all
right here are the three categories
all right there's co-stars dogs and game
shows leah pick your first category
dogs perfect i'm the dogs
okay the clock starts now
okay first down first clue the apparatus
you used to walk your dog
yes okay you bury it in the backyard uh
number two
number two yes and um
number three is um i throw a ball and
you bring it back
is mesh
did you see that ready ah yes
all right pick your next category
got it okay co-stars okay start the
clock here we
go okay number one down
uh the uh uh saved by the bell boyfriend
uh zach yes
mark paul oh oh oh
uh uh yes yes yes
your old school hubby is uh look at the
baby
what uh you're the actor who's your old
school hubby
kevin james uh no old school the movie
sorry oh
this one yes uh hold on that puzzle
is out of time um okay one more we have
one more chance to win
number three is the category of game
shows okay
number one down is a game show and the
last host was alex trebek
jeopardy thank you okay and uh
number two across is um
the blank show about couples
the blank show about couples bob eubanks
hosted it
um yes yes okay and the next one down
three across is hosted by jeff probst
survivor yes gosh darn it
leah you won which means we're giving
100
gift cards to each of our bffs and five
thousand dollars defeating america
thank you so much i literally
like have to lay down now that was so
much anxiety
i'm at home i don't really need to win
so you can only imagine
how people feel when they're doing these
shows
i have an ulcer
i straight up have an ulcer it's like
you go
like blank and you want to throw up when
you're playing game shows
your brain just shuts down like your
brain says i don't know it i don't know
it when you can know it like i go
through this with my daughter i'm sure
you go through this
when you're doing work with them and
they go i don't know i don't know you
just go just calm down
you do know it you know these answers
just relax
don't tell yourself you don't know you
know like that but that's what i do
you were just so calming just now like i
want to be your daughter i'm not kidding
i was like
listening to you and you're like you
don't know and the nails they're like
hypnotic
and i'm like yes oh thank you
leah remini i look forward to seeing you
in person
i love you i want to bring you some
candy shoes yeah
some shemend affairs
thank you so much people puzzlers arrows
weeknights at 6 p.m
on the game show network
you